what's going on guys it's your boy Joe
from Indian Gaming coming at you with
another Division two video after a lot
of research and feedback from some of
the larger content creators around a
huge amount of work has gone into
creating this new completely non generic
look and feel intro to my videos I hope
you like it
anyway I recently got back from Ubisoft
Australia where I'll floor over to spend
some more time playing the division to
the purpose of our visit was to try out
some of the PvE side of the game
missions the open world and we even
touched base with a little bit of the
endgame there has been a lot of talk
around a recent trailer that came out in
particular the spot this new faction
type known as the black tusk looks
strong organized and as well if not
better equipped than us I've seen
speculation around these being hunters
Aaron kinas first wave agents Russian
Special Forces and I couldn't confirm or
deny any of these we simply weren't told
which is good it would have been one
hell of a spoiler to know everything
about the lore of the game before it was
even released however I can tell you a
couple of things about them and where
they feature in the game after you've
completed the main story and have
reached the endgame this group of agents
very similar to ourselves sweep across
Washington DC quickly undoing all of the
work we've achieved up until this point
the previously completed missions have
now been invaded by the black tusk this
new faction is far stronger than
anything else we've come across in the
game so far they may not quite have the
acrobatics of the hunters that they have
the numbers and they coordinate very
well together flanking you if you don't
manage to control their movement and
advances on top of this their equipment
seems to be more advanced than ours
you'll see war dogs horrible turrets and
skills like ours for example they use
these drones that quickly hone in on you
and explode on impact you'll need to
play much smarter and be far more
coordinated if you're going to make it
through these new and baited missions
I'm gonna leave you some gameplay of one
of these missions now but before I go
I'd like to do a bit of a shout out for
solitaire and uber Timmy these guys were
at the event with me and some of these
sweet moves you're seeing on screen
right now are because of them both of
these guys are variety streams and a
super nice dudes I'll put a link to the
channels in the description please check
them out when you get a chance
but before you go don't forget to smash
that like button subscribe leave a
comment donate all of your savings build
a statue in my honor and send me your
firstborn
peace out
[Music]
check any terminals or laptops you find
the more Intel we collect on black tusk
the better we'll be able to count
help me
Tango's got our man
yes
asymmetric encryption protocol detected
installing backdoor protects something
juicy goes blank
put it out
engaging
Wow
three
[Music]
they're coming up on the plank I see
attempting on target Guffey I've got
your six Pico has not been running
suppressed
man down
[Music]
I'm taking two minutes
they got back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they're not dead yet division agents in
my school
deploying you eighty years
[ __ ] the man
[Music]
division agents alternating it
goodnight goddamnit
[Music]
whoa
[Music]